why
so I was a little bit hesitant about
including Heroes for Hire as part of our
Civil War discussion and the whole
reason for that is because for the most
part the Heroes for Hire doesn't really
do a whole lot in terms of progressing
the main civil war storyline but what it
does do is really kind of serve the
purpose of showing us just how deep this
rift between the superhero community
goes and we had talked about this when
we began our conversation our videos
about the Civil War then we talked about
how we will see stories like Civil War
frontline that will show us so there
really isn't anyone that's really kind
of being spared with regards to the
Civil War event for the most part
everyone's kind of choosing sides now to
do a little back story here the Heroes
for Hire was originally a group that was
founded under Luke Cage and in fact when
Luke Cage first appeared in Marvel
Comics his comic book was titled Luke
Cage Hero for Hire and for the most part
that's exactly what he was he was a
person that people could go to if they
needed something done if they needed
something accomplished so think of the
Heroes for Hire as a team as a Marvel
version of the a-team if there's
anything that you need to have done if
there is a goal that you need
accomplished or simply something you
need investigated they would be the
people you go to now the team is kind of
hit and miss when it comes to
superpowers characters like paladin for
example have enhanced abilities but
they're only slightly above superhuman
whereas you have individuals like
Colleen wing who really has no
superpower she's just a very athletic
individual and then you kind of have
people who were in the middle like their
leader misty who has a bionic arm but
aside from that there really aren't
really isn't anything that she has that
nobody else could gain just by physical
training or anything along those lines
now as the comic book begins to open up
what we actually see here is really kind
of an introduction to the team we really
kind of see some information here
showing us how it was as a team came
together because this version of Heroes
for Hire is actually the the first
iteration that we see during the events
of Civil War this Heroes for Hire issue
number one is the newest version of this
team there have been different
variations over time of course Colleen
and Misty we're really kind of
assistants are really kind of I guess
sidekicks
Luke Cage but they weren't really the
main stars now in this comic they are
and what's really kind of interesting
about this version of Heroes for Hire
is that with the exception of maybe an
individual like paladin or maybe humbug
and shang-chi and possibly Orca I'm not
100% sure where this stands this team
largely consists of women now this is a
very cool concept in Marvel Comics
because for the most part you don't
really see teams that are largely
composed of women either it is kind of a
50/50 split or maybe a 60/40 split of
men and women or it is a larger
proportional I guess ratio between men
and women where there are more men than
women but you don't really see an
instance where you see more women than
men and that's what makes this comic
really kind of cool that's what makes
the Heroes for Hire at the very least
this current version of Heroes for Hire
really kind of stand out but again these
individuals don't really have a whole
lot in terms of superpowers when it
comes to the the Marvel community as a
whole now once we get past the
introduction phase once we really kind
of see some of the escapades they got
into we see that misty and Colleen are
meeting with spider-man Captain America
and and Reed Richards and they're really
kind of enlisting the aid of Heroes for
Hire to track to track down and capture
Captain America now the big kind of
issue here what's really kind of going
on in the mind of misty is she's
concerned that not everything is what it
seems to be that they're the role will
kind of be fulfilled as far as them
being able to track down and possibly
capture Captain America but she's afraid
that once that's done they're going to
be rounded up just like everybody else
now for the most part they're in support
of superhuman Registration they think
this needs to happen I think that it's
about time the superheroes were held
accountable but again she's really kind
of concerned about this in addition her
other concern is that they have
individuals out there in the superhuman
community that are friends that are
allies of the Heroes for Hire group and
so she's a little you know a little
hesitant about being about tracking down
these individuals about really kind of
tracking down their friends and turning
them in for refusing to register not
only that Heroes for Hire because of the
nature of the work that they're in they
have a lot of contacts they're largely a
detective kind of team and so it's very
important
that they can form contacts and not have
to worry about those contacts maybe
suffering some kind of I guess
reciprocation maybe suffering some kind
of hazard of being a contact for the
Heroes for Hire now I think that one of
the most interesting parts and one of
the most important parts about this
whole conversation between spider-man
and Reed Richards and I and Iron Man is
when Missy brings up the idea of slavery
now Missy doesn't necessarily bring up
this concept of slavery to really kind
of bash them over the head but what she
says is that just because something is a
law doesn't mean that it's okay and in
fact some of the the worst laws in
history have been overturned by people
openly defying them and she really
pointed the idea of susan b anthony that
in 1872
susan b anthony had gone and voted for a
congressman despite the fact that it was
illegal for blacks to vote at the time
and that is time progressed because of
the backlash of this and because of
other events that had taken place that
that law was overturned now our man goes
as far as to say that this isn't really
kind of a black and white issue that
this isn't really a racial issue that
this is an issue of whats for the
greater good but we see the colleen
really kind of combats this and says
that the issue here is that when you
have a law that really kind of
disenfranchises people of civil rights
that it will always end in a violent
conflict of some sort ultimately the
group really kind of comes to terms with
Captain America and his staff I'm sorry
with iron man in his stance they really
kind of come to the - to an agreement
where we see that misty says that if
they are going to do this that they are
going to really kind of try to undertake
the role of capturing Captain America
she's going to need all the resources
that that Tony Stark has that she's
going to need all of the I guess maybe
the the money at his disposal not in the
sense that they're going to use it all
but in the sense that there really can't
be anything holding them back there
really can't be anything that gets in
their way
and so iron man ultimately agrees to
this and says that no matter what
happens that no matter what takes place
that they will be protected that they
will not have to you know be concerned
about the idea
of being turned in or if being I guess
stabbed in the back once their task is
complete from here we switch back to
Chinatown and we see that misty and
black hat and other members of the
Heroes for Hire are kind of meeting
together and we see that a black hat
returns with some information saying
that Vienna a well-known supervillain in
the Marvel community is helping people
escape the country she's providing new
passports providing new identities and
the people are going underground because
of it now they don't exactly know where
this is going on they don't exactly know
how this is happening but they have a
few ideas one of which is to head to the
to the shipyards because it's the easy
way easiest way to leave the country in
addition we see that humbug is able to
use his powers to talk to various
insects in order to really kind of comb
the streets and really kind of listen in
to what's going on gain information and
ultimately discover where it is that
Vienna is at now Vienna is actually near
the shipyard she's actually kind of in a
downtown underground area of Manhattan
and we see that she's meeting with
various villains to really kind of
provide them with information they can
use to leave now the villains are really
kind of a mishmash of different people
that we've seen in Marvel Comics and for
the most part we're really not going to
go too in-depth into them but we see
that a heroes for hire we see that misty
and in humbug and black hat and Colleen
and others are able to break into the
facility and they begin to fight these
super villains now we ultimately see as
things progress that for the most part
these super villains get the upper hand
on Heroes for Hire but then we see that
paladin and Schanke and Orca are
arriving on the scene and they're able
to help turn things in support of of the
Heroes for Hire ultimately Heroes for
Hire is of course successful in
defeating these super villains and we
see kind of an interesting scenario
going on here where misty goes as far as
to say that they have an upper hand on
all of these superheroes on Iron Man and
Captain America and various people
because at the end of the day they don't
know who to trust they don't know who
they can go to
but that Heroes for Hire is not going to
have that question that they can trust
each other because for the most part
they exist as a cohesive family
so as we continue with Wolverine vol 3
issue number 45 what we see is that as
with previous comics this comic picks up
from the previous events now what's
really kind of interesting here is that
we see Wolverine and they were the
Submariner engaging and physical combat
the two of them were actually fighting
because as we saw with the previous
comic name of the Submariner had really
kind of appeared and made it apparent
that he was the person that had I guess
established all of these sleeper cells
with the very least woke them up so that
they could engage in the activity or the
investigation of trying to find the
killer of named Arita now here's what's
really interesting when it comes to the
idea of these Atlanteans sleeper cells
for the most part we don't know who put
them there we don't know how they got
there we don't know when they were there
we really have no idea at what point
this whole project involving the
Atlanteans sleeper cells began we don't
know if maybe they were established
within the the first time that name of
the Submariner had inherited the throne
of pan of new Pangaea as the leader of
the Atlantean kingdom we don't know if
maybe it was after the Illuminati were
formed we have no real clue as to when
it was that this takes place all we
really know is that somewhere along the
line sleeper cells Atlanteans who were
masquerading as humans began to move
about on the surface and we don't know
what their purpose was one of the really
interesting things that we see when it
comes to a comparison between the
Atlanteans and humans is that the
Atlanteans for the most part hate humans
and this is really kind of a cool aspect
of their of their characters very rarely
do we ever really see an instance where
Atlanteans will have normal dealings
with humans they're very inhuman their
various emotes the Inhumans in this way
the Inhumans for the most part really
kind of exist off on their own they
really kind of exist totally separate
and under normal circumstances blackbolt
would never really have any dealings
with normal people and in fact his
dealings with anyone outside of his own
people of the Inhumans and their their
own territory is really kind of isolated
to the the Illuminati with name of the
Submariner it's the exact same way but
this is where the two get a little bit
different where Black Bolt says he wants
nothing to do with humans name of the
Submariner at some point along the line
seems to have sanctioned this kind of
endeavor where he is really kind of
using sleeper cells as a way to ensure
that nothing really happens because
these individuals are sleeper cells they
don't know that they are Atlanteans they
are just kind of woken up at some point
in time and so it's not as though
they're kind of reporting information
back to the name of the Submariner it's
not as though they're kind of keeping
him aware of events that they are
unfolding here on the surface they're
just kind of there at least that's the
perception that we're given of them and
so when you look at this idea of sleeper
cells the one thing to kind of bear in
mind is that we have no idea how this
started we have no idea how long they've
been there and what we'll see as this
comic really kind of progresses is that
this is a point that Wolverine raises to
Tony Stark so as we continue with the
comic we of course seen in with a
Submariner and Wolverine continuing to
fight one another and what's really kind
of cool here is that name of the
Submariner and Wolverine are really kind
of just in a knocked out drag down kind
of brawl between one another and for the
most part they're really kind of having
an even fight now we see that Wolverine
Knox name with a submariner down and as
he does he goes to of course address
himself and the two of them again begin
to fight once more now from there we
kind of see some witty banter back and
forth we see the two of them kind of
taunting one another we say that we see
that Wolverine really kind of says that
he expected better of name of the
Submariner because name of the
Submariner is royalty he is the king
he's the leader of Atlantis of the new
Pangea territory for Atlanteans and so
he thought that he would have a little
more strength maybe a little more fight
at the same time remember the Submariner
more or less says the same thing that
Wolverine has a reputation for kind of
being a murderer and it really kind of
taunts him by asking if he murders
people by boring them to death and
response to this Wolverine uses his
adamantium claws to impale name of the
Submariner now at this point Janus
attempts to come to the aid of name of
the Submariner but Wolverine
incapacitates him quite quickly and in
fact he actually takes off his breathing
mask and really kind of exposes janet's
to the oxygen-rich atmosphere now this
is one of the inherent traits of
Atlanteans in the sense that they can't
breathe our normal oxygen they have to
have a sort of breathing apparatus that
they use occasionally in order to allow
them to us survive on our surface from
here we see him through one of their
transformation darts into the neck of
Paul and Paul becomes incapacitated
stated and then we switch to this
unknown woman who is apparently put one
of their weapons to the throat of nitro
now this is really kind of a ruse this
is really kind of designed to keep
Wolverine off of his toes and we see
that name of the submarine re-emerges
shouts imperious Rex and then NOx will
reign unconscious now a lot of the one
of the questions a lot of people have
when it comes to name of the Submariner
is what does imperious Rex mean or does
it even mean anything as far as I
understand it imperious Rex has no real
importance when it comes to a name of
the Submariner it is really kind of a
battle cry it's the equivalent of I
guess maybe Thor using his hammer
picking up his hammer and shouting
Valhalla or the beard of Odin or
something along those lines to really
kind of I guess maybe get himself
rallied up or to get other people
rallied up for the upcoming conflict and
what we see is that NIM the Submariner
and this unknown woman and nitro really
kind of begin to fade away as Wolverine
becomes unconscious and then Wolverine
is knocked out entirely
now from here Wolverine comes to and
once he realizes that the two of them
I'm sorry that all three of them have
taken off he really kind of begins to
try to pick up their scent and the
reason for this is of course Wolverine
one of his most prominent abilities is
the ability to really kind of sniff
anyone out but also because Atlanteans
have a very distinctive scent and
because Atlanteans are almost never on
the surface it's not only very easy for
Wolverine to pick up their scent it's
also very easy for him to hold it just
because there really isn't going to be
an instance where he's going to lose
their scent because it's so unique from
here we see that he's able to track
their scent down to the water and from
there he really loses the ability to
track them further just because he
doesn't have the ability to swim
underwater he calls for assistance from
Ironman and Ironman appears and of
course you know Wolverine kind of talks
to him and says you know I need your
ability I need your your assistance I'm
not able to travel underwater and I have
to onion track down nitro from the hands
of member the Submariner so that he can
you know effectively stand justice for
the crimes that he's committed at this
point we see that Ironman has actually
lent his suit to Wolverine and Wolverine
has a little bit of inner monologue he
really kind of has an instance where he
I guess really kind of expressed
is what he's thinking and what it was
that led to Ironman allowing him to use
his armor initially Ironman didn't want
to use it or didn't want to do it
Ironman did not want to give his armor
to Wolverine but Wolverine pointed out
the fact that there are a handful of
sleeper agents that have been found so
far and again he points out the same
thing that we discussed earlier that at
some point along the line these sleeper
agents were installed by a by the
Atlantean people and so we don't really
know where these sleeper agents are at
we don't know who they are we have no
idea who they could be and so because of
this this is really an instance where by
they need to gain as much information as
they possibly can and so after this is
kind of revealed by Wolverine of course
he says that an Iron Man allowed him to
use his armor at this point we see that
Wolverine has reached new Pangaea which
is the home territory of all the
Atlanteans and is the one place in which
all of them reside what we also see is
that he confronts I guess named the
Submariner and name of the Submariner is
initially initially not very receptive
to Wolverine but he doesn't realize that
it's Wolverine to him this is Tony Stark
and Wolverine really kind of plays on
that well we were a Wolverine really
kind of plays on the idea that name of
the Submariner thinks he's Tony Stark
and it really kind of moves forward
accordingly what we see is that
initially name of the Submariner is
under the idea that that to his eyes
iron man wants to take nitro to allow
nitro to stand for stand force crimes
but it's not nearly going to be as
vengeful or as justified as the actions
that name of the Submariner is going to
take against him in addition we see that
one of the things that is that's really
kind of discussed here is that he had
made a bargain that he had really kind
of told nitro that if nitro gives the
necessary information that he won't kill
him and so Wolverine is again trying to
maintain this bargain he's really trying
to uphold his into the end of the deal
and this is really kind of important
here because this really kind of goes in
line with the idea that Wolverine is a
very honorable person and what we see is
that ultimately Wolverine as he's kind
of talking to name of the Submariner is
name of the Submariner says you know he
killed my cousin he killed one of the
members of the royal family and so why
should I release him you know if you can
give me one good reason
then I will let him go and Wolverine
says I will give you six reasons and of
course he reveals his claws at this
point of course name of the Submariner
realizes that it is Wolverine he tells
Janus to attack the Wolverine is able to
overpower Janus relatively fast albeit
due to the fact that the suit moves
pretty slow compared to how we can
normally move on the surface from here
we again see that name of the Submariner
and Wolverine begin to attack each other
and the two of them fight for only a few
moments or so in addition he takes one
of the women who have attacked him on
behalf of name of the Submariner and she
really kind of pleads with him to kill
to kill her because they're never going
to let name or rita go Wolverines really
kind of holding her hostage at this
point Wolverine is really kind of saying
if you don't let if you don't give me
nitro I'm going to kill this woman but
she doesn't mind dying because to her
her loyalty is to name her the
Submariner it is loyalty to the royal
family and this is really kind of the
way that most of the lanterns kind of
view the royal family of the Atlantean
people they really kind of dogmatic in
this sense to them honor is the most
important thing and the royal family is
the most important thing and this is
really kind of a throwback or kind of an
allegory to the mindset of the Japanese
people during World War two but what we
see is that name of the Submariner is
really kind of in a position where he
doesn't want to see another one of his
people die he doesn't want to see
another one of these people be killed
and so he asked the question of
Wolverine why is this murderer worth
your word and he says he's really not
but he made him a promise he told him
that if he is willing to give
information that is necessary to really
kind of highlight the bigger picture
highlight to what it was that a loud
nitro to detonate in the first place
then you know they'll go a little bit
easier on him I guess or Wolverine just
won't kill him outright
and so Nemo really kind of takes note of
this never really says that you know you
have come from the surface and
trespassed on our property you are going
to effectively strip me of the justice
that is deserved for the death of name
er of name Arita but in the end you have
honor which is something that I can I
can respect and so we see that a name of
the Submariner has Wolverine and
and a few other people taken to the
whereabouts of where Nitro is being held
where nachos kind of being interrogated
but what we see is that Nitro has killed
the man killed the husband of the woman
that Wolverine was going to kill the
person who was interrogating him from
here she really kind of freaks out the
life begins to kind of go insane and
attempts to attack nitro but we see that
ultimately Wolverine kind of gets in the
way is able to stop her and is able to
spare nitros life now initially a
Wolverine is ready to kind of take nitro
away but he really kind of
second-guesses it he says no more this
is really kind of the last straw
for Wolverine his idea was to take nitro
and to gain the information that was
necessary to really kind of highlight
the bigger picture and then hand nitro
over to shield but this is no longer
going to be the case he says no more
bargains no more victims no more
reprieves and what he does is he hands
nitro over to name of the Submariner he
really kind of grants name of the
Submariner the Justice that they felt
they were deserved and this is a very
important move on behalf of Wolverine
because what we see is that in response
to this name of the Submariner meets
with Wolverine and tells Wolverine that
the information Wolverine was looking to
get from nitro in the first place had
already been gathered and that a company
called damage control Incorporated had
given nitro the mutant hormone the the
mutant growth hormone that are really
kind of contributed to him being able to
detonate on such a scale and so with
this information the comic really kind
of begins to be comes to an end and we
see that that will rain we presume is
going to begin to go on a warpath a
second time to try to find out more
about this company and try to implement
his own plans to bring this company down
you